hi I'm Rachel and this is my friend  Dylan and we're here to show you some at  home workouts to do when you don't feel  like going out in the cold weather  try not to look maybe close your eyes  let's start by stepping to the right so  I like to just hop my hands up right in  front of my chest and then lunch to the  side and then come back Center how long  do you think you can hold this plank 45  seconds 45 seconds okay maybe 30 that  was only five take normal squat you can  add a heel raise try to pause at the top  take it into it jump and try to land  really soft on the knees really nice do  you have a heavy candle like such at  home yeah I got a couple of these laying  around somewhere  so now the way to get your heart rate up  just start running in place and  literally start taking yourself a mass  into it what do you feel this stretch  yeah 3 2